are you getting lots of questions from
your customers related to covered 19 in
this video I will walk through the steps
to help you build and implement a
rapid-response virtual agent as the
world responds to the code 19 crisis
providing your customers with accurate
timely information is crucial to keeping
people safe and informed you can use the
template in this tutorial to set up a
custom rapid response voice and chat
virtual agent that integrates directly
into your web hone social and message
channels you can launch it in 23
different languages and it's available
for any organization including
healthcare and public services
government agencies and nonprofits as
well as other industries that are
severely impacted including travel
financial services and retail let's take
a look at how you can get started using
the template your first step is to
download the dialogue flow cup in 1918
template from github link in the
description to create the agent navigate
to dialogue flow to cloud to Google com
log in and click create new agent give
your agent a name and then click create
now click on the gear icon on the right
hand side of the new agent under export
and import select import from zip and
drop the zip file that you just
downloaded from github now you're ready
to import and setup the backend for your
agent and for that you deploy
fullfillment go back to the github and
download the dialogue flow covert 19 for
ferment back in the dialog flow console
click fulfillment in the left sidebar
and toggle the switch to enable the in
line editor you'll be asked to enable a
billing account in Google Cloud console
when you're ready navigate to cloud
functions from the left panel under
source code select the zip upload and
upload the zip file that you got from
github
now you should see three intents closure
confirmed cases and debts that require
setting up Google Maps API and bigquery
API for metrics let's enable the bakery
API first select the api's and services
from the left panel then click on enable
api's and services search for bigquery
API and enable it for the Maps API you
will need to create credentials to do
that click on credentials create
credentials and then API key
make sure to restrict the key to cloud
functions API only now back in our cloud
function we need to set this API key as
an environment variable for that edit
the cloud function click on the
environment variables and add the
variable the name should be Google
underscore Maps underscore API
underscore key and then the value should
be the API key you just created and then
just deploy now you're ready to test the
easiest way to do that is to test in
dialogue flow simulator let's try an
example is it still safe to receive
packages the response should indicate
that you setup your agent correctly if
you plan on enabling the bot on your
website go to the integration section on
the Left panel and enable dialogue flow
messenger copy this code snippet and add
it to your website you can also use the
try it now button to test it out let's
say I select start screaming the agent
starts asking me for specific symptoms
and directs me based on my answers if
you want to enable this experience we
are holophone go to the integrations
select dialogue flow phone gateway and a
phone number place a call to the number
and test it out
if you want to interact with the dialog
flute API you will need to create a
service account and download the private
key here's how you would do that go to
the I am an admin on the Left panel and
select service accounts create a new
service account give your new account a
name the role would be project owner and
then click create create key will let
you download the JSON key on your
computer you will use this file in your
environment so save it open the terminal
on your local machine or any other
interface where you can run a coal
command execute export Google
application credentials which would be
equal to the location of your key file
in quotations so make sure you provide
the right location to test we will lead
a user request let's say the user asks
how can I get tested we put that in a
file called request our JSON and next we
will send this request to dialogue flow
detect intent API using the coal command
with post request option authorization
header that gets the token value via G
cloud art command and then the data gets
passed as request dot JSON and there you
have a response in JSON format all
that's left is to parse it out and do
what you need to do with it in your
custom application curl is just an
example you can interact with the
dialogue so API using other language
integrations like Python Java etc refer
to the documentation linked below for
language of your choice and that's it we
hope you and your customers will find
the rapid response virtual agent helpful
during this unprecedented time
you